basically what we have right now
is an attempt by the russian federation
to legalize something that's already
there for eight years
and do you think putin has any interest
in the diplomatic solution
if you were
strong enough
to listen
to this torrent of narratives
well you tell me what do you think
i'm not i'm not putin's uh spokesperson
he has another gentleman
security
the security council has to continue
discussing the situation this situation
been with us for eight years we have now
a new face a very dangerous face
and i was very very very much impressed
with the majority of the statements
is this enough for you no it's not
enough
it's not enough for you whatever country
you represent you know
so talk to your government and insist
that your government saves the united
nations
excuse me you said you're not afraid of
anyone and or anything so what are you
going to do
what are you going to do if they are
going to defend our country
your minister of interior says
i'm not a spokesperson for the minister
of ontario
your government just say they now expect
that the west
does something i mean that's something
the best the entire civilized community
right
yes it's not a yes west has been hit by
the by kremlin but it as you heard today
my dear friend as you heard today from
africa
and i invite you to read the african
statements
it's not about the west after all
if there was anything very important in
today's meeting it was a very very very
powerful statement by the african
ambassadors
when they spoke about colonialism
when they spoke about borders
when they spoke about imperialism
i invite you seriously to read the
kenyan statement
i invite you seriously to let your
readers know about the statement of
ambassador of ghana
i invite you seriously to share with
your readers and viewers the statements
by
gabon i invite you
to listen once again what the ambassador
of mexico and brazil said
even the even the russian ambassador
in his
concluding remarks said that the
majority unfortunately said this and
that even he
confirmed
the fact
that the majority of the security
council was not buying his
with the arguments statements who said i
was not happy don't put words in my
mouth
what do you think about the sanction
let me ask the gentleman go ahead
what do you think about the sanction
from the united states and united
kingdom
first i haven't seen them yet are going
to break diplomatic relations with
russia
what for to be emotional and dramatic
we're not in the theater it's up to my
government to decide we will take
very informed decisions and if you
followed the meeting of the
national security and defense council of
today in ukraine they remained opened
they went uh they left the room but they
said
that the meeting of the security council
of ukraine will continue to
adopt necessary decisions
the united states is convinced that
there will be a further invasion are you
there's a billion of beer for the
invasion putin said himself that he set
additional troops to ukraine so it's
going to be an
an invasion read putin's word on this
going back to the normandy format you
mentioned that is any response about
going back to the table because that
will be to re revise the men's agreement
between you france and germany we all
want to have summit
and you can uh read the statements by
the office of macron
and by the office of
the german chancellor on the issue we
are all
with the exception of russia are willing
to sit down unconditionally and discuss
in the normal format
necessary steps it's only russia who
puts conditions
the u.s said um the men's agreement is a
threat to pieces so is there hope that
the u.s ambassador said the the men's
agreement is threat to pieces so i'm not
commenting on the u.s statements i mean
they have a powerful
mission with many spokespersons but do
you think that you can really take it up
again and there is hope that diplomacy
has a chance
i said on the minsk agreements what i
said in my statement you can quote my
line in the in the statement on the
members document you held up today in
the meeting
uh
it was uh
i can show it again
right look
this one is the decree by president
putin
of 26th of august
2008
on recognition of
i think it was asitia
right
that is the decree of today
all right
it's
identical twins identical twins
you change the geography
and in the ukrainian decision
you just insert a couple of words on
minsk because there was no means in
georgia case
copy machine copy machine you know copy
next is country a b c
d
f
you can go online
the kremlin site
and you can print it yourself
right
so if you want to have an authoritative
copy
go on kremlin's site and print out
the decrease of 2008
number 1261 and the decree
of 2022 number 72.
and make a comparison ambassador
i
actually actually heard their african
speeches they were very good you're
right
but
now in practical terms
what do you expect
from the country that can help
ukraine
and my another question is
things got worse much worse than a few
months ago
is there anything that your government
will do different
or what did in the last month
oh is there anything that the government
of the russian federation can do
differently
to improve the situation my question is
is there anything that the government of
the russian federation can do to agree
with ukraine france and germany to sit
down and discuss things around the table
of normandy fall and other formats so i
would refer you to the government of
russia and to their spoke people thank
you good night